this may be the most important story we
have here Southwest has given free extra
seats to obese people I identify as
obese what is more important than this
think about it what is more important
than this and I'm going to come to you
Emily so be ready we want your ready uh
uh breakdown of this Southwest Airline
is under scrutiny for its customer of
size policy which allows overweight
passengers to request size an additional
seat for free or book extra seats in
advance with a subsequent refund this
policy has drawn praise from some Tik
Tock influencers in the body positivity
Community critics CR critics argue that
this policy it unfair to passengers who
can comfortably fit into one seat and
represents a compromise driven by woke
activism over customers overall interest
they suggest that overweight passengers
should be required to purchase two seats
if they cannot fit into one rather than
receiving an extra seat what a dumb idea
but go ahead what are your thoughts on
this I've said this on gutell before
because this is not the first first time
obesity is being woried and idolized in
the United States any other country
would be looked at gross cuz it is but
it just makes me regret ever dieting in
my life because if I was obese and
hideous I would have way more brand
deals i' probably have a fat wallet
right now I'd get free seats apparently
on Southwest and my question is why are
we lying to ourselves that something
like obesity should be glorified and
when you said Tik Tok influencers like
the light bulb went off in my head like
all right that's why it's being
normalized cuz of these freaking idiots
on Tik Tok and it it it goes Way Beyond
obesity it's like we're trying to
normalize things that they're not
normalized for a reason you know being
Fat's not healthy fat in your body is
likely going to cause cancer to produce
its cells in your body cuz it's not
healthy exercise is good for you eating
healthy is good for you glorifying
obesity which I see all the time on Tik
Tok is not like a new trend that we
should be setting and then secondly
they're trying to do this for I'm going
to assume like equality and and stop
like fat shaming whatever fine body
positivity but here's what I've been
trying to say loudly if you want true
equality this goes to whether you're a
Jew a Christian Muslim an atheist black
white yellow purple fat skinny doesn't
matter you want equality stop pointing
out the differences you know you don't
need pride month you don't need your own
seat on a plane for free you don't need
to highlight the differences if you want
true equality thinkx act normal e like
by the way she's a beautiful woman
imagine if she was thin healthy healthy
not thin healthy they'll never let her
go thin because it ruins their entire
agenda this story just came out do you
understand how much that's going to
backfire that means really obese people
are going to start going on Southwest
can you imagine the nightmare if you're
on that plane and they're in the exit
roll they're not going to be able to
help if hits the fan they're going
to be that's so insensitive but it's
true they asked you like can you perform
emergency duties by the way you know
when you're onth Southwest Airlines and
you're just on your flight and you ask
the most important question the most
important question you got to ask is is
this a full flight they say no when they
say no if you're with another person
there's strategy that can pull you
somebody sits window somebody sits aisle
and people come in and you say hey
somebody spilled coffee here coffee no
they said no one sit here oh I don't
want to sit there and they go away and
so and then you try different things
okay yeah you know one person can say
this guy smells there's so many
different strategies you can take but
when it's a full flight and your time
we've been on these well we're sitting
there and you're just looking at a
person coming you're like oh God I'm
begging you no and then they say hiy oh
my God how are you I I really travel in
Southwest but I pick people out of the
lineup and um you I usually try to get
on I hey you guys want to team up to get
let's just sit together everybody IM no
i get on and I try to sit as far forward
asio and so you know I I make sure that
I you know get wait can I point out my
my Southwest story I've never flown in
my life I had a really weird transfer
from Florida to DC and you H you've
never flown in your life no no Southwest
I'm a big Delta fan um so anyway when I
get to the plane I'm like boarding and
I'm like this flight looks really full
so I go and I didn't get my seat
assignment yet so I ask for it and they
go oh you're not guaranteed a seat on
the plane and I'm just like but I I was
build $480 for this ticket like so
where's my see and they're like oh
buying a ticket doesn't guarantee you a
heard but what what was that what does
that mean so what did I just buy I
bought like a raffle that made I get on
the plane no I'm confused nobody
experienced that before on South I have
something I've had that happen before
wait what do you mean I literally bought
a ticket and they're like buying a
ticket doesn't guarantee you a seat on
the plane I swear this is this was
Southwest it was Miami to 100% I've
heard that happened before the the
biggest problem that I have with this
it's going to result in
bump they got to bump somebody if
someone says I'm too
big let me say the biggest problem I
have with this is it it's that the
antithesis of what America should be
founded on which should be a meritocracy
the better you do the more you read the
more you learn the more you try the more
you stay in shape the better the reward
mechanism should be the problem with
this victim culture right now
is they're rewarding the people that
shouldn't be rewarded and we have to use
language to cuddle them to make them
feel like so that now they're not fat or
obese they're customers of size of of
what size I have a size two it's just a
size exact two or four not the reality
is you should be paying double your fat
ass is sitting in two seats pay double
but now you want to give them two free
seats what it's like remember the people
with like now we're going to be doing a
a people who have have horrible credit
scores and have been laid on their bills
we're going to give them a better
mortgage price than the people who
actually have good credit scores that
have been paying all their bills on time
it's backwards it's illogical no wonder
people are like sign up yeah by the way
when I sit next to someone and they're
like like obese I tell them off the Jump
cuz they're I'm like listen if your
shoulder blubber and your tricep is L
I'm taking a nap on you I tell them I'm
like I'm going to use you what Rob were
you going to say something well as the
only I would say out of shaped person in
the
room but you sell it I don't think you
qualify for two seats though no um but I
can tell you this you're a great ass
though go ahead I've started working out
eating healthy again and part of the
reason was because I took a flight and I
was uncomfortable in the one seat and I
went this is not a fun way to live
feeling uncomfortable all the time no
instead you're going to get a brand deal
exactly better than mine it ends up
making people it incentivizes bad
behavior because it doesn't give you any
effort to try and change your physical
being i instead of getting an extra seat
my my uh rout is your mic on yeah I hear
him you hear him I hear him but I go
keep going my route was to start eating
healthy to start working out what's the
incentive if they're just going to
continue to cater for
for's Reon for
toits and
lose you know what this vault's on you
bro so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right
here